hello everybody and welcome back to the
stab your friends in the back game where
we're trying to survive and no one is
more important than me so let's just get
back to it
I I actually do feel kind of bad if
you're if any if either of you watching
this later
then I shouldn't establish did you you
shouldn't just blast at me I mean I'm a
cop on there's I don't I don't mess
around but I'm sorry if you were
progressing a while I I do apologize so
anyway but I got from there dead dying
courses is I got a backpack now what
this means I don't exactly know tonight
Lee how do I I don't know what this does
like I have two backpacks now but what
do they do
oh is that just like oh do i I have a
backpack on my back and this is just
like my trophy for killing them I I
don't have an option to like hold it and
I don't need these knives
I don't need the evidence of the murder
that I committed so I'll just go on my
merry way okay so what I'm gonna do now
is um I'm just gonna survive that's
basically all I can do at this point
kill my friends survive kill my friends
kill some zombies up kill my friends
it's a hard life but someone's gotta do
it I uh hope I don't run into them later
cuz they probably want vengeance
okay enough that put that all in the
past hahaha oh my god ah these bottles
and bowls okay whoo I guess I deserve
that oh my heart okay stop I barely
found the place where there's a lot of
other people and don't trust anyone this
is the part where I don't like hey I
really don't like these type of games
because it's always just like I try to
be nice first I'll try to go like hey
I'm not gonna kill you and then they
shoot me in the face that's how these
games used to go would it oh what does
it mean non-global inventory I don't
know okay let's try this again and oh
man alright okay so if pack of
cigarettes in the back of an ambulance
isn't that counterintuitive what is this
thing can I go up in this thing oh
alright
that guy had like everything that guy
had a gas mask and a bigger backpack and
uh some awesome gun that just one shot
the hell out of me then again I wasn't
at full health but still oh he probably
had my number from a while ago across
Tommy running around oh I don't blame
him huh I did murder two people so
whatever alright
no now though I'm recovering from that
okay there are holes in this building I
must assume that I can actually go up in
this building and if I can go up in it
that means there's probably goodies near
the top I'm guessing that's where I'd
hide some goodies so let's just make our
way up and hope there's no one else in
here with like a sniper rifle waiting to
kill someone okay all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to go up top first and
then then might make my way down the
floors if I don't find anything up top
some weird building design here I don't
remember a lot of pre-apocalyptic
buildings just having wooden planks that
go straight up but um no I'm not a civil
engineer I'm a biomechanical it okay
here's another campfire does that mean
does that mean that someone was here
like a real player or does that just
mean that like that's a remnant of like
survivalist out here in the nobody land
I don't know he's away I don't see
anything up here it's highly possible
that someone already cleared this out
err
huh my heart still found Mars bounding
now that I know that players are out of
here I knew it was gonna happen
eventually
I just didn't know it's gonna happen
that heart attacking Lili okay
I'm not finding anything like wait is
that something or is that just sunlight
I keep thinking that sunlight is
actually something when it's not so
makes me look like an idiot and I don't
like looking like an idiot I look like a
lot of Sun but not an idiot there's
nothing here I'm guessing there has to
be like some sort of algorithm that
decides where and when to drop items cuz
I believe I looked into like into it on
Daisy there are specific zones where
items could appear but they were totally
randomized as to what they were so I
don't know if it's the same way I'm
guessing like an ambulance is it's kind
of like first aid consumable stuff in
buildings it's like guns and whatnot and
all around the world I don't even know I
probably shouldn't have names myself not
markiplier in this game so if you seem
someone by the name of not markiplier
not me not me at all again with the cat
okay someone needs to explain this to me
like why I'm recording like four
episodes of this someone please write me
an email detailing exactly what I'm
doing why I'm doing it how I can survive
what what is the best tactic am I
supposed to go up in the buildings am I
supposed to not go in the buildings I'm
gonna need your help I'm learning slowly
but it's not doing it not doing whoa is
that
nothing there's nothing there's a whole
lot of nothing I'm wasting time going up
into this building huh hey come on give
me something give me something baby come
on do it for me nothing absolutely
nothing I think my best bet is just
traversing laterally as opposed to
vertically
I'm like constantly on a state of being
on edge because I just know I know I
know bad things are gonna happen to me
who's that no it's just a hole in the
wall I keep thinking shiny things are
actual pick up apples but no oh wait I
was here oh I made a circle okay
don't need to cross over and it's
someplace over there and now I'm not
even worried about the zombies anymore
I'm worried about the players good holy
hell man that would suck if you like put
I mean I guess that's the thing about
this type of game is that permanent
death and all that but if you like put
hundreds and hundreds of hours into a
character and just add yourself blown
away like headshot from across the map
and all of your goodies just come
tumbling out I think there's got to be
some sort of reoccurring save or some
sort of permanent stat like the cash is
maintained in between playthroughs like
when I find cash I noticed that the
number keeps going up so I'm assuming
that that has some permanence to the
game and will help you progress but as
far as the levelling of each individual
character goes it doesn't seem to be any
continuation it just makes sense
hence the death and dying and brains all
over the ground myths of it all oh I
don't know I don't know I'm seeing some
army trucks here I'm hoping there's
gonna be like a gun or something no I
have a bad feeling that someone cleared
it - Oh a safe zone
market global inventory press I what was
that no no no you said something global
inventory what was that oh oh oh there's
whoa this place is here oh my god good
god this place is gigantic okay I didn't
know that there was a map character
globulin it said something about a
global inventory oh man
sell these for money we're okay on the
map they're like a dollar signs so if I
go north and east I should hit whatever
this is I'm assuming maybe that's some
place Atkins Oh God hello J Rosa hi I'm
totally not cool you want to be partner
friends I'll call you J ray cool all
right let's go cool come with me I'm
turning your back on you I'm trusting
you I'm going north where's north this
way going this way so follow me I got
he's gonna have a dad God please please
did I I have no items of worth of value
but you can kill me if you want to he's
trying to kill me they always have way
don't get me okay
we're gonna get inside he's gonna kill
me god damn it
that [ __ ] he really wants to kill me
we're gonna have to come and get me now
biznitch come after me bro he'll out
into the danger zone why did he want to
kill me so badly
probably because everyone wants to kill
everyone but that's besides the point
can't there be a little bit of stability
in this poka post-apocalyptic world I
totally forgot that there are even
zombies in this game I am so dead
I am so dead Olli crap I am dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead okay so I went
north what what is that what's going on
over there
I'm gonna throw myself into the ocean Oh
God
okay go yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god
yeah oh that does not look good oh my
goodness oh my goodness I can't even
stop to recuperate my sprint meter oh
I'm so dead I'm so dad I'm sorry I had
that jerk jerk shown me in the bud where
my back turned on I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead
oh my god I'm dead I can't do nothing
wow that's not good
fine take me brillo I got one of you so
hey there's some right that's dumb
player level increasing ah gosh dingus
ah
there was cash right there or did I drop
that I don't know oh I don't know I
don't know oh man okay
I know there's something I'm missing
guys I really do I know there's
something I'm missing and I'm trying to
I'm trying to get to it but who bear
with me as I'm trying here cuz I am
really trying okay I don't see anything
with global thing I bought the game and
got these super duper things I don't
know what they are I don't know how they
help me I don't know anything something
in settings No okay let's just get back
into the game this stressful game that's
gonna give me a heart attack
haha I get so stressed playing these
games okay you know what
oh whatever Huff it up suck it up
okay where am I let's view them that I
am that me am i right over something is
that where I am like right there okay if
I am that means that there's something
over here there's like a dollar sign
what does that mean you go in here is
this uh okay
how can I tell which direction okay yes
yes yes so I'm in this building and
somewhere in here there's something to
do with the dollar sign not that I have
any thing to do what is that what is
that what is that hello yes okay cool hi
hello haha I die oh whoa cool oh my god
that's a lot of money that's not a good
sound okay so someone's shooting
something oh that's so cool that okay
there's no guns for sale but there are
small things I don't have a lot of cash
but I have these gold coins could help
me I don't know someone's trying to
survive down there just shoots tougher
it's gonna come up here in two seconds
and blow my brains out but whatever no
global unit or what is this Grim Reaper
what is that oh well whatever it makes
me look cool I guess what is what is
what is this what is this I don't know
what that is
okay uh let me just get something to go
oh I don't have any money for that oh
this doesn't help me there's nothing
useful I can buy with the gold stuff so
I guess it isn't sort of like uh pay to
win deal is that be cheap
oh look at all the pretty things Flair I
don't okay so that's interesting at all
I could sell stuff to him for money so
if I had there like that soap and stuff
I would be able to do something with
that but right now I'm kind of just
totally broke totally broke oh man look
at this place
it's just this is a whole different game
than what I had prepared for guys haha
not that that's a bad thing but man oh
man ah all right
editing safe zone so in the safe zones I
can press I I think at any time and then
shop and get my stuff out of the global
inventory whatever the thing is so
anytime I have something that's why
people go to the safe zones to be able
to sell only goods
the only goods that are available are
outdoors in the danger area where I need
to go I need to be careful cuz there's a
guy right over there but this is a
surprisingly deep game when I first
thought I thought it was just gonna be
uh urban exploration find stuff few
other plays but no there's actually some
more to it and I kind of like that ah so
if you go into like a safe zone the
players are gonna be there you could
easily get murdered by another player or
maybe you can't shoot another player in
a safe zone maybe that's why you only
shot me when I left I don't know but I
don't think I want to no no I don't
think I wanted okay any goods any
goodies goody goody gumdrops
nothing is someone clear this out
probably actually this looks familiar
maybe this is back where I first started
okay I hear you noise is here you noises
I'm finally in the wilderness again on
my own what's that well I saw something
like a player
Hey okay you know some games are scary
because of who booga-booga the boogie
man's coming to get you but some games
are scary because I wanna die I don't
wanna die I don't wanna die dumb horror
games combine the two but whatever
there's a sense of value in the
character that I'm playing because I
sincerely believe that like I could do
this I can I can win this game if I if I
was really able to try but man oh man am
I not doing well okay let me try to get
up over this it seems to be some sort of
segmented area huh
I just got to go where the players
aren't and where the zombies are not I
got I guess that doesn't exist except
for the first area I was Blake I didn't
realize how good I had it in the
beginning this is definitely where I
been before I recognize this area I
didn't realize how good I had it when I
didn't see anyone or anything and was
only picking up items I should not I've
tried to shunt down zombies and shoot
them in the face that is where I went
wrong what I should have done was thank
my lucky stars that I had the perfect
opportunity to be great and oh my god is
he getting dark ooh is that a thing ha
that's a thing
Oh crunchy bar company crunch car Cara
Maria Reba
goodies goodies goodies goody goody
gumdrops
I got goodies I'm gonna keep these or
sell them I don't know what I'm gonna do
but maybe I'm gonna survive just a
little bit longer how am i doing that
okay I'm entering some sort of grayed
out area I don't know if that's like a
limit to the map maybe this map is only
uh restricted right now to this area
because I don't know player sighs a
current
snaggers no come on
oh don't find me oh can I hide oh no no
no no no no no no oh I'm boned
oh don't find let me go leave me oh god
I'm so dead how does this keep happening
Oh probably my highest pitch scream I've
ever had please don't tell anyone that I
did that oh I'm so dead I can't sprint
my whole way or else they won't recover
and then I'll be totally boned I also
can't swing swung or else I'll also be
boned how do I get away how am I
supposed to get away oh okay
maybe oh no no no no no I'm boned I'm
boned I am just sincerely dead unless I
can kill this one is it just the one
hello hello did I lose it did I do
it got dark I just realized that I've
been playing this entire game with the
same expression on my face just the
sense of pure terror just no don't kill
me please I want to live okay looks like
this area okay that's probably yeah
that's the border so there's nothing I
can do to get over there oh okay
so I just got to be careful I can't get
away from him I can get away from him
that much is certain I can I just gotta
be able to calmly and collectively go
along my merry way don't sprint too much
don't do anything then what is that what
is that what is that what is that what
is this thing the lawn gnome what is
this here are you here what are you
doing what do you look so weird you're
disturbing me okay
another surge is underway Oh good-o
wondering when one of those was gonna
come by again hey I see you there
I know there's got to be goodies in here
because it's all walled off and guarded
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
seem to be walking on a tightrope ledge
I'd rope in an urn like a shadow in the
night okay dropping off we're not we're
still walking on the edge I live my life
on the edge baby I probably shouldn't be
able to do this but I'm doing it so
screw you guys I'm gonna take whatever I
can get
how about that okay how can I get in
there cuz that looks like it has some uh
maybe not no this is where I was before
I recognize this place there are no
goodies here is this walled off to try
to prevent me from going else this is
where I died dead very dead
well stabbed repeatedly in the bud was
that a goodie I think I see something no
just flashing lights what is this work
no damn it oh oh oh look on okay you
know what I'm tired of playing around if
anyone comes near me player or otherwise
they're getting a lot of bullets in the
face I don't care who you are
I care what you do if I see you you're
dead got it good I'm gonna crawl down
here cuz I'm all out of time for this
part so anyway my hands are shaking
uh-huh I'm so nerve-racking this game oh
but it's good I guess so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
empty more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you
in the next video
Hey
hi
oh not you
lady where you cried
I cry ladies because your old fugly no
one loves you is that why you're alone
in a forest